[Música]
bienvenidos a canadá en las américas
café o con su nombre de cariño el castor
cibernético los saluda paloma martínez
desde nuestros estudios en montreal aquí
en el estudio vamos a ir viendo a
nuestros colegas presentes por comienzo
por la derecha pablo gómez varios como
estas pablo la nardo gimeno como estas
leonard a chapman como estas palomas muy
bien muchas gracias qué bueno que están
todos aquí tenemos dos invitadas
especiales también marie-christine doha
de la universidad de ottawa y leila
félix de la universidad de quebec aquí
en montréal cómo les va a ustedes muy
bien gracias gracias
la invitación vamos a estar conversando
con ustedes un poquito más adelante de
aceite de palma de luchas sindicales y
de un informe que fue presentado
recientemente en colombia y vamos a ver
una presentación aquí en montreal
también entonces en un segundito pero
para presentar el programa en general
todo lo que tenemos para hoy a nuestros
oyentes y como le llamamos a los que nos
ven pablo escucha escucha bien
concepción les damos la bienvenida a los
que nos siguen por facebook live y
también aquellos que nos están viendo
por youtube por nuestro sitio internet
www.sii.cl en el programa hablamos de
festivo del festival internacional de
películas muy
cortas muy muy muy cortas con pablo
también una propuesta de solución al
problema de la escasez de mano de obra
en canadá en quebec particularmente o en
canadá en general leonor de la escasez
es en canadá la propuesta es para que ve
que perfecto y con leonardo una
conferencia a poco que tiene un tema
central que es el desafío a la viene el
desafío de la privacidad en realidad
creo que es lo que se quieren desmarcar
por esto lo hacen una vez por año
siempre presentan cosas muy especiales
este año el todo giró en torno a la
privacidad es el desafío de la
privacidad leonardo va a tener trabajo
hasta el siglo 23 está sufriendo tantos
embates no lo que pasa es que todo lo
que esté programado por computadora
tenga que ver con alguna máquina es
jaque hable si uno hace una barrera la
sacan claro y vamos dejando huellas
digitales por todos lados que no nos
damos ni cuenta la privacidad va
retrocediendo y yo creo que sí que
estamos en una época de vulnerabilidad
total en las redes
qué bueno que cualquiera que esté dentro
conozco gente que hasta hoy no entra no
tiene cuentas de hotmail porque tiene
que trabajar pero trata de no tener
redes sociales
no tener elementos que puedan abrir este
pero comencemos primero con nuestras
invitadas entonces marie-christine
dorgan decíamos de la universidad de
ottawa y laila celis de la universidad
de quebec aquí en montreal que vienen a
hablarnos del informe y a la vida por
fin daremos todo ese es el título
oficial es un informe sobre los
trabajadores y las trabajadoras en el
sector del aceite de palma en colombia
que fue presentado o más bien comandado
de alguna manera por el centro nacional
de memoria histórica de colombia para
comenzar me gustaría que nos hicieran un
pequeño resumen de lo que se dice en
este informe es un informe muy grande
pero digamos en a grandes rasgos que es
lo que dice este informe quién quiere
comenzar leila bueno sí perfecto
entonces el informe lo que
es la situación las violaciones de
derechos humanos los crímenes de los que
fueron víctimas los trabajadores de la
industria de palma y lo hace
ilustrando a partir del caso del sur del
cesar en el departamento del cesar la
parte de shurja y
lo que muestra es que los trabajadores
de la industria de la palma en esta
región a partir de un momento en el que
hicieron una huelga para mejorar las
condiciones de trabajo y los salarios
empezó un proceso de represión que no ha
terminado un proceso de represión que
implicó para ellos la pérdida de cientos
de trabajadores asesinados por grupos
paramilitares pero también por la
guerrilla por supuesto por el estado por
las fuerzas militares de policía
estatales torturas masacres gente que
tuvo que salir desplazada exiliada
etcétera entonces el informe constata
violaciones a los derechos fundamentales
como los derechos humanos pero también
al derecho laboral y una digamos una
amplia gama de tipificaciones criminales
en colombia pero sólo para tener en
claro cuándo fue esa huelga la huelga
fue en el 78 1978 entonces una de las
particularidades del informe es que es
un informe que hace un recorrido
histórico que va más allá de los que
simplemente él
periodo que se cubre con las políticas
actuales de verdad que es desde los años
80 hasta hoy estamos hablando de 40 años
si es animarme le cubre todos esos
santuarios también estamos viendo ahí
las las imágenes del informe que puede
ser bajado a partir del sitio internet
del centro nacional de memoria histórica
de colombia marie christine doran tengo
la impresión que usted por lo que
estuvimos conversando antes de entrar en
estudio y en días pasados usted tiene
cifras con respecto a esta represión
contra las organizaciones buen y cales
en colombia lo que sabemos de manera más
general paloma es que justamente este
informe digamos revela muchas tensiones
porque habla de un proceso de represión
fundamental en colombia que tomó parte
del sac y fue parte importante del
conflicto en el conflicto no sólo
hubieron narcotraficantes y otros
horrores pero también había una una
dinámica que intentaba justamente
impedir que la sociedad civil pudiera
organizarse a través
por ejemplo de los sindicatos esto es
muy importante porque lo que sabemos es
que durante el conflicto el número de
violaciones graves de derechos humanos
bueno el más el mayor número corresponde
a los paramilitares es eso está
demostrado por las naciones unidas pero
viene en segundo lugar la fuerza pública
y el ejército esto es algo que no
sabemos mucho verdad y este este tipo de
represión además según encuestas que han
hecho el cinep muy importante centro de
investigación en colombia se puede
demostrar que habían algunas regiones
como justamente la región donde se
cultivaba la palma donde la represión y
los asesinatos la tortura por parte
lamentablemente también de fuerzas del
estado eran más fuertes o sea la
conflictividad social también es un eje
para entender la violencia en la
respuesta
digamos hiperviolenta del estado de los
grupos paramilitares y también bueno ahí
también entran las guerrillas de otra
manera pero digamos porque no estaban
necesariamente en contra
de los conflictos sociales pero de todas
maneras cometieron crímenes pero quiero
decir que esto es muy importante y ese
informe justamente revela hasta qué
punto esa dinámica antidemocrática cosas
que para nosotros son un derecho
adquirido no poder organizarse y
convocar la sociedad eran prohibidas en
colombia y lo siguen siendo hasta cierto
punto pero ustedes participaron entonces
en la presentación de este informe aquí
en canadá y no es aleatorio porque
justamente el centro nacional de memoria
histórica colombiano ha tenido digamos
financiación por parte del gobierno
canadiense e incluso hay hayan habido
reuniones entre indígenas canadienses
indígenas colombianos porque es
importante para canadá conocer este
informe qué relación hay con canadá
directa o indirecta compañías extra
compañías canadienses en colombia cuál
es la conexión
lo que hay que saber es que canadá tiene
intereses económicos en colombia'
importantes y canadá ha sido un país que
tradicionalmente ha apoyado diferentes
intentos de conseguir la paz en
colombia' la situación cambió en algún
momento pero canadá ha estado
acompañando esos diferentes como país
amigo el proceso de paz acompañando a
diferentes niveles
yo diría que
lo que hay en este momento es un cambio
de gobierno en colombia que no hace que
es diferente lo que es lo que está
pasando acá un cambio de gobierno en
colombia que se ha ido derechizando
realmente de forma muy fuerte no es que
hemos tenido gobiernos de izquierda en
colombia pero teníamos un gobierno
liberal en el anterior gobierno de juan
manuel santos y tenemos un gobierno de
derecha abiertamente en este momento que
es un gobierno guerrerista quien no
quiere la paz así lo han dicho
abiertamente y que están dispuestos a no
quiere la paz en el sentido de que
piensan que hay que doblegar los actores
armados desde forma a partir de una
estrategia militar
yo creo que marie christine que
completaran bueno totalmente de acuerdo
pero digamos hay que precisar algo muy
importante el trabajo que se estableció
fue con el centro nacional de memoria
histórica anterior la dirección de ese
centro del equipo de investigadores yo
tuve el inmenso privilegio de conocerlos
y de trabajar con el centro durante un
rato en el 2017 eran gente que realmente
querían democratizar la memoria vas a
abrir el espacio para que no se escuche
solamente a las voces de los que
exactamente convienen ir más allá
justamente de ser relato acerca de los
narcotraficantes y los guerrilleros es
decir hay algo más de fondo y en este
momento cuando usted mencionó que el
informe fue comandado es importante
precisar que el centro o sea la antigua
dirección del centro mando abrió la
posibilidad a que la gente la sociedad
civil en colombia pudiera hacer sus
propios informes obviamente y siguiendo
una metodología muy rigurosa con
expertos y todo pero desde abajo la
iniciativa se se abrió ese espacio que
es único a colombia yo he trabajado en
chile argentina y no se nos ha dado de
ninguna manera algo semejante al
contrario hubo que emplear mucho para
que la gente pudiera héctor ya la
memoria bueno entonces ese informe ya se
estaba preparando cuando se cambió la
directiva del centro
y nunca y en canadá nunca se pensó que
iba a cambiar tanto la dirección de
digamos del centro al nivel de que por
ejemplo el presidente duque nombró dos
directores que fueron totalmente digamos
rechazados por la comunidad
internacional por la onu y por la
comunidad en colombia y ahora nombró una
persona que si bien es muy criticada
pues ya vemos sus a sus actuaciones no
entonces la idea justamente es decir que
bueno hay que reorganizar ese movimiento
de democratización de la memoria desde
todos los espacios y justamente cuando
los colegas de la universidad de los
andes que como bueno a lo mejor los
auditores saben es una universidad de
mucha importancia en colombia ellos
digamos tiene un peso simbólico de que
ellos hayan querido abrir el espacio
para que se se hiciera un lanzamiento
con los trabajadores y trabajadores de
la palma
y la
cambio toda la dirección del centro de
memoria histórica o solo se cambió el
presidente mire sé qué bueno cambio el
director y cuando ya se hizo efectivo el
cambio mucha gente del equipo anterior
casi todos los más importantes
comisarios del que habían trabajado
durante muchos años se fueron digamos
ellos dieron su dimisión disculpen será
reemplazado por
por otros o bueno ahí todos los detalles
no se lo podría decir porque la verdad
es que como nosotros hemos concentrado
los esfuerzos en seguir el trabajo de
memoria desde como otros espacios lo
único que sé es que los principales los
pilares digamos sobre todo de esa misión
de democratización de la memoria ya ya
están afuera y algunos albéniz estando
esa gente afuera que esto se haga
público ahora
porque es porque después de 40 años de
investigación porque eres 40 años de
esfuerzo de cambios en cabezas que
querían que no querían porque es ahora
que será esta salida a la luz del
informe el trabajo de la investiga el
periodo más bien que cubre esta
investigación son más de 40 años pero el
trabajo de investigación ha sido en los
últimos dos años tres años sobre las
memorias de estos trabajadores es un
trabajo que ya estaba realizado casi
totalmente antes del cambio de la nueva
dirección y lo que se hizo fue que como
la nueva dirección no aceptó presentar
el informe oficialmente algunos
profesores y otros investigadores en
colombia decidieron hacer igual el
lanzamiento del libro público porque
como decíamos ahora estas cuestiones
políticas sobre la memoria que es lo que
se cuenta el conflicto y las
posibilidades de que contando lo la
verdad se sepa y no se vuelva a repetir
son cuestiones que debía salir a la luz
pública y cómo varios investigación
investigadores lo han dicho en colombia
en un conflicto que lleva más de 60
de historia la verdad no es un
privilegio es una necesidad si queremos
pensar que un día el proyecto cambie
claro cuál es cuál fue y es el interés
de los grupos paramilitares y de
instancias gubernamentales
organizaciones como el ejército por
ejemplo en esta represión específica
contra los trabajadores del aceite de
palma esto es lo que no me queda un
poquito claro porque porque está ese
objetivo
comenzó lo que hay que saber y es el
informe se inscribe en un proceso de
verdad esas políticas de verdad que son
que quieren ponerse en
institucionalmente up después del fin de
un conflicto colombia tiene un histórico
largo de políticas de verdad sin fin del
conflicto desde el 2005 hasta hoy y lo
que pasa es que es este informe es en la
primera vez en la que se hace un informe
oficial sobre un tercero en el conflicto
entendiendo que no son directamente
actores militares sino actores civiles y
principalmente actores económicos que
participaron en el conflicto armado la
importancia yo pienso de hacer público
lo que está pasando allá es que hasta
ahora siempre hemos dicho y la verdad
sea un poco limitado a establecer
quiénes fueron los criminales los
asesinos los paramilitares y quiénes
fueron las víctimas pero lo que llamamos
los terceros en el conflicto que
beneficiaron económicamente que lograron
acumular riqueza
de la guerra ha sido pocas veces
juzgados y es importante también porque
la industria de la palma en colombia ha
sido desastrosa no solamente frente a
los trabajadores sino a la población en
general
este informe ilustra lo que pasó en el
sur del departamento del césar pero la
industria de la palma ha destrozado la
vida de miles de campesinos
afrodescendientes e indígenas en
colombia y bueno eso no es lo que cubre
el informe pero hay que decirlo talar el
medio ambiente también afectado esto
terriblemente en las selvas bueno y eso
sigue para solamente agregar porque está
perfecto pero eso es la destrucción del
medio ambiente sigue en este momento hay
compañías establecidas allá que siguen
entonces es muy importante y fue también
por eso que los colegas los
sindicalistas y los colegas de las
universidades que hicieron que ese
trabajo se hiciera hasta el 2018 hasta
lo más tarde posible y para demás
demostrar que la dinámica sigue siendo
vigente entonces si lo vimos esta semana
con la presentación del informe de la
comisión sobre las mujeres
niñas indígenas asesinadas o
desaparecidas aquí en canadá canadá
tiene su propio proceso de memoria y de
reconciliación con los pueblos indígenas
con las comunidades nativas en lazos en
la sociedad que paralelos podemos hacer
entre el proceso de memoria y de
búsqueda de la memoria de la
reconciliación en canadá y en colombia
brevemente
y yo diría que hay dos cosas primero que
estamos haciendo
estamos enfrentando políticas económicas
y políticas coloniales muy importantes y
que las respuestas de los gobiernos
primero pero también de una parte de la
sociedad es cerrar los ojos todavía o ya
en canarias en colombia cuando decimos
que cuando el informe de las mujeres
indígenas asesinadas y desaparecidas en
canadá dice que hay un genocidio en
curso no es que hubo en 1800 es que hoy
hay un genocidio en genocidio en curso y
que todo mundo se alarma y que este no
eso es muy radical en cambio decir nos
es muy radical lo que estamos haciendo
como sociedad mayoritaria frente a los
indígenas y tenemos que parar eso ahora
asumamos nuestra responsabilidad es lo
mismo en colombia o sea un informe que
involucra no a los paramilitares que
ellos fueron los que hicieron los
asesinatos sino a las empresas
económicas que beneficiaron de esos
asesinatos y que seguramente no lo
podemos pagarlo en su momento también
absolutamente lo respaldan bueno
en el informe se ilustra cómo habían
para militares en las oficinas en las
tierras de las empresas ahora habría que
hacer un proceso jurídico que nos
permita demostrar que una
responsabilidad penal pero hay al menos
una responsabilidad política que tenemos
que asumir y aquí algo que agregar bueno
en ese sentido si hay un paralelo muy
importante estoy totalmente de acuerdo
con leila en el sentido de que de alguna
manera en los dos procesos vemos cómo se
abre un territorio para la inversión
económica es lo mismo con los indígenas
en canadá es una realidad que todavía no
se discuta mucho pero sabemos en el
norte de quebec por ejemplo que las
compañías mineras se establecieron allá
sacaron las comunidades y todo eso se va
de mano hasta de la mano con un proceso
justamente de de colonización de echar
la gente afuera de decir ustedes ya no
van a poder vivir de la caza y de la
pesca porque eso realmente no da mucho a
nivel económico
entonces vivan en reservas lejos de
escultura y todo y eso también
obviamente hasta el día de hoy hay
territorios que están muy contaminados
en el norte de quebec donde yo no sé
las compañías no son responsables
entonces yo creo que nosotros aquí en
canadá estamos recién empezando y
gracias a la valentía de las mujeres
indígenas canadienses vamos a poco a
poco abrir los ojos acerca de un proceso
que es muy semejante digamos a la fuerza
fue más lenta en canadá pero es la misma
vas a decir el territorio express para
explotarlo de cualquier forma si se
requiere eliminar personas como en
colombia o si se requiere hacer un
genocidio cultural y también efectivo
como en canadá pues lo haremos no acá de
los intereses marie christine de hanley
las félix gracias por venir a hablarnos
de este informe que fue presentado
también aquí en montreal pero es un
informe del centro nacional de memoria
histórica de colombia y a la vida por
fin daremos todo sobre los y las
trabajadoras en el sector del aceite de
palma en ese país en colombia muchas
gracias gracias a usted de dónde viene
la frase ya la vida podemos podemos
darle esto es a vecindario nación a la
vida
lo daremos todo y a la muerte jamás
daremos nada es una frase
de chucho peña jesús peña que es una era
un poeta colombiano que fue asesinado en
colombia muchas gracias por venir acá
ustedes nosotros vamos a continuar con
un vídeo de la aplicación para que la
gente que nos quiera ir siguiendo a
través de la aplicación con su teléfono
celular también lo haga leonardo nos
puedes ir contando cómo funciona es
aplicar el descuento cuando aparece el
vídeo y está en realidad pueden ir al
sitio de internet de radio canadá
internacional
a la derecha arriba en la columna
derecha aparece el link para ir hacia
las dos tiendas más populares esto es la
tienda de apple y la tienda de
de android para bajar la aplicación
cualquiera de las dos aplicaciones
digamos en cualquiera de los dos sistema
operativo se puede bajar la aplicación y
ustedes están viendo ahí un recorrido de
la navegación super instintiva y con la
posibilidad de ver por ejemplo amigable
y para ver nuestro nuestro programa se
puede ver ya lo hemos demostrado uno
puede entrar la aplicación y ver nuestro
programa directamente desde la
aplicación sin necesidad de andar
navegando que hacer cosas hay mucha
gente que ya hace si no tanto en español
porque parece que los españoles los
hispanófonos
por la lengua les gusta más navegar en
cuestiones culturales
por ejemplo en francés ha tenido un
éxito estrepitoso siguen bajando cientos
y cientos de veces por semana no solo
tenemos un
un poco menos poco menos pero igual
sigue siendo importante es importante
porque aparte uno tiene el acceso mucho
más directo
uno puede guardar por ejemplo me gustó
un artículo que escribió pablo que no
suele suceder
y después no si está bien está bien está
bien en cualquier momento viene el
derecho así la venganza la venganza será
terrible en sí
así que bueno está disponible ustedes
hacen clic ahí se van a nuestra página
internet y ahí tienen las dos opciones
para hacerlo desde los que tengan la
plataforma android o desde lo que tenga
la plataforma de apoyo
y ese a partir del creo que el 10 u 11
peruano
bajando ahora se recuerden si se
acuerdan que habíamos pedido a nuestros
oyentes que nos enviaran vídeos a dos de
sus zonas tardan encuentro en enviar
fíjate que gustavo lucas de melo uruguay
no se envió es un vídeo
pero hace mucho tiempo y apenas lo
localizamos lo vamos a ver y lo vamos a
ver hablan y es un vídeo de gustavo melo
de una zona de su ciudad creo que es
como un monumento vamos a verlo a ver si
lo podemos estar
yo veo como que dice 200 en el monumento
y me pregunto si será la fundación de la
ciudad de melo en uruguay
y había sonido la ciudad de melo cerro
largo
uruguay este la fuente de los 200 años
que se comerán año 1995 aquí en la
ciudad un saludo
son 200 años de la ciudad de la ciudad
siguiendo que suele seguir en línea es
decir exactamente y bueno yo para
alentar a nuestros oyentes a que nos
sigan enviando y oyentes y escucha
viendo rededores a que nos sigan
enviando vídeos les voy a mostrar un
vídeo que yo tomé en la ciudad de
montreal y peligroso
[Música]
vamos a ver el vídeo que yo filmé a ver
pero no hagan eso si no tienen a
comentar
[Aplausos]
cuál es la calle paloma
es la calle sant llega
en el barrio sí creo que fue el único
diego cielo azul en la calle entonces
además no había nadie en ese momento no
sé por qué es lo que estaba cerrada la
calle atrás de mí entonces la que está
estaba libre por eso hice por eso que
anima la bicicleta
como el cuento mamá mamá voy sin pie
mamá mamá voy sin mano uno pierde los
dientes en este tipo de casco
no es lo que también quería mostrarles
porque además pueden mandar los vídeos
pero también nos pueden mandar fotos
entonces pablo para mostrar cómo hacer
eso nos hizo un pequeño álbum citó de
fotos y escribió estamos en la ciudad de
melo fue fundada el 27 de junio de 1797
95 o sea que son 200 años en el 2005
y en cualquier momento dentro de un par
de semanas festejamos un nuevo
aniversario el 27 de junio
muy bien el vídeo tenemos otro mensaje
de j alves que dice hola desde ritmos
key gracias por su programa que tengan
un buen día así que yo veo vídeos en los
vídeos
yo digo ritmos quisiéramos que
bueno veamos ahora las fotos que pablo
estuvo tomando acerca de acá y pablo van
a ver que tiene muy buen ojo fotográfico
[Música]
está tapando el árbol justo ahí vamos a
estar nosotros así este es el edificio
entonces
mañana el cielo estaba así entonces me
llamó la atención y me dije paloma está
presentando el programa
el cielo estaba así
entonces todos nuestros oyentes nos
pueden enviar fotos videos para que los
deseos que que cuánto tiempo de duración
un minuto y si quieren hablar como hizo
gustaba explicándonos un poco el efecto
por si no nos mandan una pequeña leyenda
algo que temer eso para que entendamos
de qué se trata así que háganlo
no lo duden por facebook nos pueden
enviar también por correo electrónico
amlat
heresi net punto sea o por nuestra
página facebook
y canadá en las américas lo [ __ ] tienes
algo así acá y me saludó fue en realidad
gustavo dice la fuente lo sacó guardo yo
por eso soy el comunicador y no
matemático la fuente de los 200 años se
hizo en conmemoración a los 200 años de
la ciudad en 1995 700 en el 900 cumplió
200 años en el 2000 como dijimos tener
razón del 95 ya va cumpliendo casi 220
hoy leonardo nicolás emanuel rayman dice
muchas gracias por hacerme conocer
canadá y para eso aprovechando el
mensaje de leonardo nicolás y manuel
pueden entrar en el sitio de radio gran
internacional
rc y net punto sea barra s de español y
en realidad está en todas las lenguas
pero en español particularmente pueden
entrar a ver escenas de la vida hay un
pequeño vínculo sobre un
si lo podemos mostrar aquí en realidad
si tengo tiempo
[Música]
la historia es que es en la vida es un
proyecto del grupo de los seis que ahora
son cinco y pronto serán siete es el
grupo de radios
temáticas
eso tiene una razón de ser es porque uno
del grupo se fue y entran dos nuevos
modelos espero son cinco y van a ser
siete eso la tengo clarísimo entonces lo
que se ha propuesto el grupo de los seis
es hacer mostrar la ciudad a partir de
elementos que son comunes en las
ciudades como por ejemplo un estadio un
mercado un aeropuerto entonces en
escenas de la vida en este sitio que
nosotros tenemos en nuestro sitio de
internet ustedes pueden ahí si vemos lo
del vídeo bueno justo esto en inglés
pero no importa anterior inglés ustedes
ahí tienen sketches of life que van de
escenas de la vida entran en esa página
y van a encontrar
que tiene el primer episodio son las las
iglesias segundos estaciones de tren
tercero son los mercados cuarto los
aeropuertos y se viene el estadio de
fútbol y eso es de los seis países que
forman parte o formaban parte del grupo
5 países porque como sabemos no se fue y
vienen dos y ahí ustedes hacen clic y
fue el grupo de los seis ya les digo
porque no me acuerdo
croacia me román pero con rumanía esta
suiza la mayoría
polonia república checa
y bueno nosotros en gradas y se viene
sin tengo ninguna confirmación oficial
pero el que pone que puede que vienen
dos países más muy bien entonces son
radios internacionales como nosotros
como nosotros y lo que hacen es
justamente mostrar a través de fotos hay
no se ve porque se directamente con él
con el proyector de aquel lado lo que se
veía en el mercado
entonces
bueno entonces uno ve las fotos y son
fotos con audios light con fotos y
sonido ambiente del lugar dio día de
aportando audio día programa por decirlo
en años donde va mostrando
digamos la esencia de esos lugares tan
particulares que son en realidad el
corazón de la ciudad y entonces va a
haber perdón palomita y entonces va a
ver si nuestros escucha veedores quieren
verle el aeropuerto de montreal quieren
ver las otras los distintos aeropuertos
de estos estos cinco países lo pueden
hacer yendo a nuestro sitio internet hay
un pequeño banner donde se puede hacer
las tengo que interrumpir porque tenemos
que hablar de nuestros reportajes de la
semana entonces antes de que se nos pase
el tiempo más rápido vamos con el
reportaje de leonora hoy vamos a hablar
de hablar vamos a hablar de un problema
serio que existe en todo el canadá pero
en este caso es corresponde más apunta a
que ve que es la falta la escasez de
trabajadores temporales extranjeros
estamos en pleno verano y conversamos
con fernando borja de ferma que ve que
es el director de este organismo donde
el planteo que hace él y en nombre
también de otros
y de otros granjeros de quebec declaran
que la situación es bastante seria
normalmente para esta época están
esperando a 15.000 trabajadores
extranjeros todavía no han obtenido
todos el permiso y entonces para venir
cada vez dice que el papeleo es mayor es
una burocracia entre y entre las
solicitudes del momento en que presentan
los trabajadores hasta que el gobierno
las acepta porque todo esto está dentro
de un marco de un programa especial
entonces tiene que tener la firma del
gobierno canadiense pues es un programa
federal
finalmente para hacer la breve entonces
a la historia es que fernando borja del
organismo firme quebec que sin fines de
lucro y en lo que hacen ellos es
coordinar todos los aspectos
relacionados con la contratación de
trabajadores extranjeros hacia
administración logística logística
asesoramiento en fin finalmente es un
encargado de todos los trámites según la
demanda de las empresas finalmente ellos
le hicieron una propuesta al gobierno
canadiense y lo
antes de esta propuesta es que el
gobierno canadiense ya mostró que ésta
tiene señales positivas hacia esa hacia
ese proyecto a esa solución del problema
que lo califican de endémico y
finalmente lo que ellos dicen es que se
trata del empleador de confianza esa es
la figura que ellos han creado el
empleador de confianza es un empleador
que siempre contrata a los mismos
trabajadores extranjeros que siempre
está haciendo la misma solicitud por
ellos que siempre respetó las reglas del
programa que eso también es importante y
que para ellos sea más fácil entonces lo
que el propio que ellos proponen porque
es un grupo además es que este que el
gobierno les permita a estos empleador
de confianza o empleadores de confianza
saltar todo ese trámite de los papeles
de la burocracia dado que hace años que
son los mismos trabajadores y que se les
permita una vez que estén presentados
que directamente se lo apruebe porque
ahora lo que él dice también es que un
trabajador que quiere venir acá tiene
que hacer su solicitud ahora tres meses
o más
de venir cosas que antes llevaba dos
semanas y que además no debe ser fácil
de hacer porque no puedes tampoco
calcular cómo es que tiene antonio
arriola con la temperatura de la estaca
logrando el calma los cultivos o ahora
están tan cosechando fresas en el mes de
octubre entonces la mano de obra es muy
necesaria ya los estudiantes están
estudiando en esa época entonces si es
muy serio el tema y él dice que cada vez
más la gente se está jubilando hace
falta más trabajadores entonces también
aumenta el número de demandas y en ella
se leerá tiempo se está retrasando todo
entonces me pareció que es interesante
esta propuesta del empleador de
confianza y de que el gobierno
canadiense ya está discutiendo de
implementarlo al año próximo entonces
toda la información sobre este proyecto
y esta entrevista con fernando borja de
fm de leonora chama está en nuestro
sitio internet www.bcn.cat nos hablas
dónde está ha sido el éxito
internacional de película pequeña y 6 y
de películas muy pero muy cortas es
interesante este festival está en la
vigésimo primera edición que del
festival que después de diez años de
ausencia regresa nuevamente aquí a la
ciudad y que comienza justamente este
viernes
exacto hasta el 16 de junio próximo
uno de los aspectos interesantes de este
festival es que se lleva a cabo en 70
ciudades del mundo hay 20 países
distintos
simultáneamente quiere decir que a
partir de este momento en 70 ciudades
empieza el festival o sea todos tienen
el mismo material tienen tres hay cinco
categorías tres es el mismo material y
las otras dos categorías le permiten a
cineastas locales presentar sus propias
entonces son los organizadores del
festival en los
tintos lugares que las denuncias que van
a seleccionar los cineastas locales que
vamos a participar y bueno se presenta
de todo cuando dices corto de 44 minutos
máximo la parte uno va al cine mira
también factor y porque no la podemos
ver esa
y si hay tiempo si hay tiempo se pueden
presentar incluso en el reportaje que yo
hice la entrevista puse un cortito
entre otra vez que es muy interesante y
bien entonces para no alargarnos el
récord
entonces está está abre hoy sus puertas
y se lleva a cabo en verdad
y pueden entrar al sitio internet del
festival que es tres cubos pero donde un
reportaje ya partir de tu reportaje
donde se originó esta idea pablo schab
es bueno es aquí aquí en acción en estos
10 años ausente porque como se hacen 20
ciudades distintas entonces durante ese
periodo se presentó en otras ciudades y
ahora regreso nuevamente a mente
muy bien bueno entonces el festival
internacional de películas muy pero muy
cortas microfestival piano bueno
y la nada de una de las de privacidad en
la conferencia de japón si todos los
años a partir de más o menos en esta
época en california se hace la worldwide
developers conference es la conferencia
de desarrolladores de apple a nivel
mundial donde presenta apple como
empresa todas las cosas nuevas para que
los desarrolladores externos puedan
participar de los proyectos de apoyo en
este caso anunció la presentación de un
montón de cosas por ejemplo en los
nuevos software para el teléfono los
nuevos software que se van a presentar
para las computadoras las capacidades de
estos no software los nuevos software
para los relojes inteligentes y llamó
mucho la atención porque en cada una de
las presentaciones se hizo énfasis en la
cuestión de la privacidad
y porque la gente a partir de cambridge
analítica fue como en el punto inflexión
o la gota que rebalsó el vaso hasta ese
momento se sabía que si no investigaba
pero no tanto y a partir de ese momento
uno se dio cuenta que en realidad nada
de lo que esté en internet está a salvo
privada así que es nada de escrivá
entonces a pose entre comidas puesto las
pilas como para desmarcarse de sus dos
competidores más grandes que son google
y vall salía windows y android con su
con su google
para hacer de la privacidad uno de los
ejes principales de la marca y en este
caso deja dejó de lado la presentación
de su nuevo iphone por ejemplo se puso
de cabeza con el tema de la privacidad y
una de las cosas de los anuncios de la
privacidad es que va a generar uno
cuando entra el teléfono en un teléfono
tiene que entrar con una sesión de app
entonces lo que pretende es hacer que
uno entre con una sesión de apoyo al
navegador
en un nombre de usuario y password cada
vez que comience el cada vez que uno
comienza a navegar en un navegador x uno
entra y se lo vea se mete a la página
con ese es el nombre y esa contraseña y
a partir de ahí navega en seguridad
porque todo lo que en las distintas
páginas piden va a quedar en
dentro de la en el registro de apos pero
no va lo que nosotros navegamos no va a
quedar en el registro de las páginas es
una solución bastante interesante
claro por supuesto porque por supuesto
que así que es interesante para ver y
para reflexionar sobre esa posibilidad
en todo caso en la conferencia terminó
ayer no termina hoy
exacto hoy hoy viernes y bueno hay un
montón de novedades en cuanto a las
cuestiones de ajo la más particular es
el reportaje completo con toda la
información mañana por la mañana en el
sitio internet de rcma punto sea y yo
les presento una entrevista que tuve con
uno de los cineastas de una nueva una
película que no necesariamente nueva
pero que tuvo estuvo en formación en
creación durante cuatro años que se
llama antropoceno la era humana
y sigue el estudio de un grupo de
investigadores internacionales que están
investigando profundamente lo que los
seres humanos hemos dejado como huella
en el planeta y de alguna manera te
imagino
sirven las imágenes se pueden dar cuenta
que hay digamos hay belleza en todo eso
de alguna manera el fotógrafo que lo
saque acompaño a los dos cineastas hizo
todo lo que pudo porque sean bellas las
imágenes y al mismo tiempo son
profundamente impactantes porque con los
humanos hemos creado mucho desorden
miren esto por ejemplo los elefantes
anillos los colmillos de elefantes que
están provocando la extinción de ciertas
especies las minas profundas lo que se
hace con lo que sacamos de las minas y
bueno es preocupante porque a largo
plazo que es lo que estamos dejando para
los los niños para los jóvenes que como
sabemos están están en pie de guerra
porque dijeron
en que algo cambie basta y tienen razón
de alguna manera entonces está película
que es una película canadiense que ganó
un premio como mejor película canadiense
en el 2018 pues bueno está ahí yo les
dejo pedacitos delante de la película
con pedacitos de entrevista con nicola
de pan sie que es uno de los cineastas
canadienses detrás de este proyecto así
que ahí lo dejo en el sitio internet de
radio canal antes de irnos y un top fun
miriam alarcón dice saludos qué lindo
verlos hemos subido de paloma y las
fotos de pablo corazoncitos así que
había más más comentario bueno ya no nos
queda tiene unos los guardamos gracias a
todos por acompañarnos gracias queridos
colegas colección colega y nos vemos la
próxima semana aquí en este mismo
estudio en este mismo canal
así
[Música]
e